[Applaudissements]
ça lui chante et bonsoir je sais pas
lequel choisir jeudi les trois du coup
vous vous l'aurez remarqué donc moi je
suis s'appelle la même ambiance qu avec
louis ont baissé de finir sans en
rigolant un peu donc je présente moi je
m'appelle anthony wyand hec voilà donc
moi j'aime bien mettre l'ambiance comme
ça où la viande pour mais l'ambiance est
cool et la richesse que nous avons dit
hec en plus si les couleurs cacao lui
c'est sûr qu'il est fils d'ambassadeur
alors je vous aurais tu le quittes suis
pas fils d'ambassadeur c'est juste qu'à
des quotas d'accord on fait ce qu'on
peut
c'est vraiment ce qu'on peut donc voilà
donc moi je vais c'est d'amener un peu
de bonne humeur un peu de sobriété dans
ce tête à l'image de ma présentation qui
s'appelle très sobrement le conclusion
voilà et qui contient environ 0 slide
donc on va pas parler de deux pyramides
qui se renverse comme siméon avec des
références culturelles
moi ce que je faire si j'essaie de
revenir un peu sur toutes les
présentations que vous avez entendu sur
quelques petits aspects essaie de les
rendre un peu marrante et donc vacances
par siméon puisque je viens d'en parler
siméon il nous dit que quand il fait le
tour du monde en vélo ils trouvent de
l'hospitalité chez des gens inconnus et
moi je vous dis on peut pas faire ça
partout où tu vas parce que prenois un
endroit par hasard dans le monde par
exemple paris si tu vas à paris que tu
arrives en sueur avec un vélo que tu top
chez quelqu'un cette personne va ouvrir
la porte la première chose qu'elle va
dire ça alors déjà avant de toquer chez
moi si on prenait une douche
ça m'arrangerait d'accord et ensuite moi
merci au revoir
alors que tu as rien demandé tu vois
c'est pas la même ambiance teulère et
siméon il nous parle aussi un peu de
l'écologie
moi je suis pour l'écologie faut
défendre l'environnement n'a pas tous le
même point de vue dessus par exemple
donald trump way lui quand il a commencé
son mandat pour préserver
l'environnement
il a nommé au gouvernement un climato
sceptiques y a pas besoin de vannes je
pense juste va d'abord ça n'a aucun sens
et moi je pense que je sais pourquoi il
prend des décisions qui n'ont aucun sens
donald trump en fait une de ses
premières mesures quand il arrivait à la
maison blanche ça a été de faire
installer deux télés supplémentaire dans
sa chambre il attend la télé dans sa
chambre quant à trois télés dans ta
chambre
ce que tu les utilisent pour enlever
décision tu vois je pense que ça lui
pour le créancier là en train de zapper
quoi qu'il kardashian se serait fait
trompé par kanye west
vous pouvez me sortir les origines de
cugnaux et s'il vous plaît merci son
arrière grand oncle était mexicain pour
faire pour lui faire payer ce qu'il a
fait à kim kardashian on va construire
un mur d'accord enfin construire un mur
sur qui prend des décisions comme ça
doit être comme toi donc réussi mais on
a eu une équipe d'autres ont les
l'alexandre si on m'explique heures qui
nous a parlé entrepreneuriat nous a
parlé de sa start up à moi j'ai un seul
problème avec les startups aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il ya beaucoup d'engouement ans
vers l'entrepreneuriat et du coup
aujourd'hui même les idées naze elles
trouvent des financements
c'est à dire que aujourd'hui et c'est
pas une blague
il ya une start up qui commercialise
uniquement des tongs décapsuleur
ou des capsules euse je sais pas comment
ça se dit sur le recto c'est une tong et
au verso c'est un décapsuleur tu vois et
dans la vie un décapsuleur ça coûte 2
euros une paire de tongs tu me retrouver
à 5 euros tu vois donc quand additionne
les deux ce n'est pas 50 de ça fait 7
euros tu es e
il vend 250 balles et ça marche
et d'un côté c'est infligeant et de
l'autre c'est un peu rassurant parce que
je vous dis que si ça marche pas dans
l'humour pour moi je monte une start up
qui vendraient par exemple des tabliers
râpe à fromage toi c'est à dire que au
recto c'est un tablier et au verso c'est
une râpe à fromage et je m'adresse à 100
euros
et c'est sûr que ça va marcher et pour
revenir au temps décapsuleur le pire
c'est pas la personne qui a eu l'idée un
peu naze de créer ça parce qu'on a tous
déjà eu des idées un peu chelou tu vois
ça nous est tous déjà arrivé de passer
devant notre frigo d'ouvrir la porte du
frigo la lumière s'allume de rien
prendre à l'intérieur du frigo et de
refermer la porte très lentement pour
voir exactement à quel moment la lumière
ses peurs dans le frigo que ça nous est
tous déjà arrivé à la touche de citer un
peu bizarre non mais le pire du coup
c'est pas c'est pas suffi et le 10 à 6
kg à un investisseur quand on lui a
piqué l'idée des tons des capsules est
yes je mets 4 millions je veux ça
partout sur la terre cet investissement
là c'est sûr que c'est un peu un bof
c'est le même ce tome c'est sûr c'est le
même qui a dû investir dans les crocs je
connais les crocs
ou est ce que c'est les crocs et je
comprends pas moi les délires avec les
crocs quand tu regardes des crocs et a
l'impression que c'est une passoire
pourquoi on va mettre nos pieds dedans
et et roger j'ai fait l'effort une fois
de parler avec une personne qui avaient
acheté des crocs et fin des fois et en
fait son seul argument s'était fait que
c'était confortable et cette personne
m'a dit pour cet opus fort achètent des
crocs et moi je lui ai dit toi tu penses
à montfort
quand je regarde ses crocs je suis un
confortable en fait de ma vie c'est à
dire que la seule fois où j'ai posé les
yeux sur ses crocs j'ai attrapé une
conjonctivite
c'est très rapide j'ai perdu l'usagé de
la vue très très rapide on a eu delphine
aussi des filles c'est très fort c'est
poignant
elle raconte que l arrivée à pôle emploi
a 40 ans et elle a su rebondir et ça
vraiment ça montre une force d'esprit
que moi personnellement je n'ai pas
parce que moi personnellement si
j'arrive à pôle emploi à 40 ans déjà je
commence par pleurer corps dans le
quatre ans et ensuite je rebondis toi
mais un petit rebond
c'est à dire qu'au bout de quatre ans je
recommence à prendre des douches voix
c'est très très lent qu'au moment très
très petit robot tueur c'est seulement
au bout de sept ans que peut-être je
commence à chercher un emploi et je
pense que pour avoir la force qu'elle a
peut-être que je met à courir comme elle
fait ludique elle court beaucoup et moi
j'ai un problème avec la course parce
qu'en fait quand je commence à courir je
me pose des questions existentielles sur
la vie parce que je suis tout seul ces
choses sur mon solitude donc là je
commence à courir je me suis auto on n'a
pas encore trouvé deux stages pour
l'année prochaine
et très vite je m'arrête de courir j'ai
pas envie puisqu'après sinon je vais
pleurer
et quand les gens ont passé je veux dire
comme c'est le vent en fait c'est le
voir c'est pas facile on a eu mauricio
ensuite alors la mauricie ont mangé
aucune van aelst on peut juste
l'applaudir le reste est vraiment très
forte
on a eu louis juste avant moi c'est
assez fort là c'est un témoignage assez
poignant et ça me donne envie moi aussi
de vous faire un témoignage du coup j'ai
envie de témoigner de partager un peu ma
vie avec vous donc il parle du fait
qu'il a failli se noyer et moi aussi
j'ai eu des petits problèmes avec la
piscine dire que je me suis cassé une
dent à la piscine l'année dernière je
vous racontais l'histoire
en fait je voulais limitée naruto et des
gens qui connaissent la route et aussi
tous ces français qui connaissent pas
c'est globalement un mec qui court comme
ça d'accord pour comme ça et il va très
très vite d'accord et on a un délire
avec des potes n'est pas limité du coup
je sors de l'eau jeudi libère les
imagine si naruto était avec nous comme
en mille tons il courait le court au
bord de la piscine en mode naruto
d'accord tout se passe très bien on se
marre on rigole ça passe très bien
jusqu'au moment où j'ai eu la brillante
idée de m'arrêter de me dire hey les
gars vous imaginez comment ils
plongerait naruto s'ils étaient avec
nous et je me place comme ça c'est une
histoire belle quoi je suis là en me
deux oppositions naruto de projets
finalement et comme je suis très bon
public je me fais rire moi même et donc
je souris et je plonge la tête la
première sur le sol je me pète une dent
et quand je ressors de l'eau il ya une
ambiance un peu bizarre parce que moi je
suis assez énervé parce que je me casser
une dent et mes potes qui me regardent
et ils sont il est juste qu en fait
juste très très court voilà mon
témoignage poignant et
j'essaie de faire comme oui mais je
pense que ça n'a pas marché et ensuite
on a eu il y as il ya celui là commencé
sa présentation en parlant du tu
préfères et c'est utile m lulin tu
préfères assez philosophique
donc il a pu en faire un tête par la
suite mois avec les potes c'est pas le
même genre de tu préfères tu vois on est
là en soirée on est tu préfère avoir la
même coiffure que donald trump wallon
les sourcils de françois fillon
c'est vraiment le tu préfères tu vois
c'est passé pas loin d'un côté et une
coiffure constituante a peur que des
chevilles parts et de l'autre tu as les
sourcils tellement large qu'on dira
paillasson toi c'est pas l'homme de loi
ne change pas en faire appel et il ya
six part du fait qu il faut être parce
qu'il faut être passionné aussi pour
réussir sa vie et ça résonne un peu en
moi du coup je vais me présenter un peu
plus en profondeur là j'en profite et
donc sommes aux jeunes à chaud c'est une
école de commerce hec paris
officiellement ou officieusement fait ça
je sais jouer en josas
je sais pas s'il ya des gens il ya des
gens qui connaissent leur jeunesse ici
ok c'est globalement une ville où il ya
hec et un auchan donc en fait si t'es
pas étudiant et que t'as pas besoin de
faire tes courses c'est pas utile pour
toi d'accord passe-passe taf son choix
donc voilà je suis de cette école là
donc c'est une école de commerce
rien à voir avec votre école
d'ingénieurs parce que pour vous que
vous avez des compétences techniques
vous vous y connaissez en chaussée en
voirie c'est ça c'est ça non à l'essai
voilà vous avez des compétences
techniques vous comprenez qu'on reparle
parce que sinon je peux parler en direct
africains mais ça paye le même délire là
on passe à peu la même ambiance mais du
coup fin au moins en théorie vous avez
souvent des compétences techniques alors
que moi-même en théorie j'ai aucune
compétence
d'accord c'est à dire que moi entre mes
cours enfin je crois pas tout les
intitulés de mes cours entre business
performance management et supply chain
opérationne management c'est très dur de
s'y retrouver
du coup je me suis spécialisé dans le
stand-up moi je comprends ce que ça veut
dire
je comprends un peu le principe de
l'humour et donc j'ai jeu consiste à
dépenser 70 dernier mais ça fait plus
longtemps que je pratique un peu
l'humour
j'ai une sorte de déclic on va dire en
seconde j'ai publié sur facebook une
vidéo de dix secondes la veille d'un dst
de svt et ce jour là j'avais eue ils
sont plus d'une centaine de likes en
très peu de temps et 80 commentaires
avec des lol xd x ptdr
ptdr xd d d d d d d d
c'est ce genre de commentaires où tu les
vois aujourd'hui la pitié pour
l'humanité donc voilà je vais plus cette
vidéo et ça a bien marché et parce que
moi son ex pour moi c'était énorme
à cette époque à cette époque mois sur
votre profil gère environ 3 lakes et un
commentaire de ma grand-mère tiens je ne
savais pas qu'on m'envoie un message
privé donc dans ma tête je me suis dit
ok va si bien écrit une chaîne youtube
et pour moi je me suis dit que ça allait
marcher
musique comme norman cyprien ce que
squeeze mr vie j'ai d'avoir des millions
d'abonnés
j'ai créé ma chaîne trois ans après
j'avais 12 abonnés parce que j'avais
créé tous comptes youtube factice je
m'attendais à un match et du coup ça
marchait pas du tout youtube pour moi en
fait ma première vidéo c'est pas une
blague ma première vidéo
c'était une vidéo
s'appeler le ridicule et c'était
globalement une vidéo deux mois pleins
de photos de moi
ridicule voilà c'était un powerpoint
gênant de moi et je les fais de mon
plein gré c'est à dire que j'avais pas
perdu pour combien on n'avait pas fait
un tu préfères à voir avec il ya ce
vraiment si j'avais perdu je l'avais
fait ça de mon plein gré et et mois donc
après l'internet voulais me lancer dans
le stand-up et donc j'ai dit à mes
parents voilà après le bac j'ai fait du
stand up toute ma vie et ils m'ont dit
non tu vas faire des études et moi dans
un élan contestataire et de rébellion
j'ai dit ok et du coup j'ai fait deux
ans de prépa et j'ai atterri à hec et
quand j'ai dit à mes parents que malgré
hec je voulais quand même faire des
blagues belmont déshérités c'était très
rapide
tu vas encore faire des blagues et les
viandes hachées notaires du coup je dis
+ d'héritage très rapide et l'a
récemment il ya trois jours
ma mère a eu un terrible choc on est en
train de dîner il m'a regardé me fais
fiston ne payer 15000 euros l'année pour
que tu étudié à chaud c'est donc pour
les trois ans ça fait quarante cinq
mille euros
est-ce que tu as pris des cours de
blagues à hec non tu nous dois 45 euros
maintenant tout de suite 45 kg et du
coup malgré ça je fais quand même du
stand-up faisait où j'ai commencé en
septembre et je joue dans un bar qui
s'appelle le pana mart a fait donc c'est
un bar à paris nous joue là bas très
simplement parce que c'est la seule
scène qui m'accepte en fait et et pour
ceux qui connaissent pas en fait c'est
une scène ouverte
donc c'est à dire que il ya non
seulement des artistes inconnus comme
moi qui peuvent y jouer il ya aussi des
artistes très connus peuvent y jouer
comme norman farhi romaine freyssinet il
ya cas d'el maleh aussi qu'ils jouent
oui c'est moi quand j'y suis j'ai pas
envie de passer pour la compétition et
demandé des photos enfin le mec un peu
excité de faire le fun parce que en soi
quand on se rend compte là bas moi je
leur font sur leur lieu de travail tu
vois donc quand on est là bas on est un
peu entre collègues tu vois
même si j'ai conscience que je suis
débutant dans l'humour et que moi je
compare à l'emploi une blague de toto tu
vois dans l'humour très très faiblement
et du coup moi ça m'arrive de croiser
gad elmaleh et le jour il a posé le
regard sur moi comme je voulais pas le
faire le mec hyper excité j'étais hyper
calme toi il pose son regard sur moi il
faut des faits salut mec je lui dis
salut mec comme si c'était un pote avec
qui on avait grandi ou au bled envoie
des blocs tu vois si je pense que j'ai
paniqué en fait et du coup je joue là
bas et c'est vraiment une scène qu'il
permet de tester des sketches et c'est
vraiment une bonne ambiance donc on peut
rencontrer des artistes et c'est connu
là bas
donc tout ça pour dire que pour moi le
stand-up ça a été un déclic ça a été un
peu un un grand réveil
voilà même s'il n'y a pas de style c'est
de faire des efforts et je pense qu'on a
tous besoin aujourd'hui surtout de la
société dans laquelle on vit
je pense que c'est facile de se laisser
asphyxier un peu par les médias et par
les réseaux sociaux je pense que à trop
vouloir nous faire rêver on peut ne plus
savoir comment apprécier la réalité
donc c'est important de trouver quelque
chose qu'on aime une passion choses pour
lesquelles se battre et donc moi si
j'avais juste une seule chose que
j'aurais que vous reteniez finalement de
ma prestation aujourd'hui cela d un seul
message à vous faire passer ce seraient
les suivants n'essayez pas d'imiter
naruto autour d'une piscine
d'accord vous vous réveillerez avec une
dent moi c'est pas super sympa comme
vous réveiller merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]